[Music]
prepare for a film that only exists so
non nerds will recognize the blonde guy
in the Avengers door you've seen great
superhero films you've seen terrible
superhero films now prepare for a
superhero film that's just kind of I
mean I guess they did the best they
could adapting a comic book about a
bratty Spaceguard journey to Asgard the
land of Viking myth where everyone gets
a pointy hat the gods live inside a CGI
pipe organ and the only way in or out is
through the Rainbow Road level from
Mario Kart meet Thor the least relatable
Marvel heroes since Doctor Strange he's
an idiot demigod prince with a magical
hammer that really needs to buy a vowel
Yaya but Thor isn't the only God in town
beat Loki Thor's evil stepbrother who
will stop at nothing to betray his
adopted father with the help of his real
father
I will conceal you and you can slay him
where he lies in order to betray his
real father to impress his adopted
father
that makes even less sense than his plan
from the Avengers not a plan
meet Odin Thor Loki's dad who pretty
much guarantees that one of his kids
will grow up to resent the other only
one of you can ascend to the throne both
of you were born to be kings Oh
and all these rejects from Lord of the
Rings Game of Thrones and Xena Warrior
Princess struggle with the former god of
thunder as he stripped of his powers and
banished to these two square blocks in
the New Mexico desert there he'll
acclimate to our strange earth customs
like ordering in restaurants he'll care
traffic safety and force purchasing
horses just dogs they give me one of
those large enough to rock watch as Thor
turns to Jane Foster for help
a brilliant astrophysicist with super
model good looks that just happens to be
single and who immediately falls in love
with or for no good reason
make that six reasons ABS so right along
with Thor as he loses then regains his
magic powers hooks up with Jane saves
two different realms from destruction
and learns the virtues of patience and
humility all over the course of a long
weekend seriously this whole movie takes
place over two and a half days
starring Thunder from Down Under
Pokemon The Godfather Idris elbow Lord
Zedd from Power Rangers one bro girl and
important
the doors obligatory movie so Loki dies
at the end it comes back to life by the
end of the credits that's got to be some
kind of record hey screen junkies if you
like my voice
how about clicking that big subscribe
button then huh also wanna see Lucius
Fox himself read the Fox then click the
box to the left to see us waist Morgan
Freeman Robert De Niro Michael Douglas
and Kevin Klein's time reading dumb
stuff speaking of which my voice can
punch your face in the face Dead or
Alive you're coming with me
goody goody gumdrops Dayman fighter of
the night man champion of the sun' easy
peasy lemon squeezy